this video is sponsored by bookwalker
you know what i
like anime you know what i
also like isaikai anime
bet you're learning something new today
i like talking about anime and i like
talking about isa car anime
but one thing i don't normally get to
talk about is the inner workings of
anime itself
i mean what could i a guy who just
started doing anime reviews in his
bedroom for fun
with zero actual industry experience
really tell you
about what's going on behind the scenes
thank god i can just let other people do
it for me
combatants will be dispatched is a new
isakai anime airing
right now a new light novel adaptation
coming from the same author as
connoisseur
and i was lucky enough to get the
opportunity to go behind the scenes at
animation studio jc staff
to see the people making it how it was
being made and really asking the
questions i always wanted to know
about what goes into making an anime
adaptation
so i'm here right now at jc staff
and i'm going to be walking through the
entire process
of combatants will be dispatched now
walking me through the studio will be
the anime producer himself
so what's your role as an animation
director or just
a director of an anime i should say
foreign
you obviously have a choice in what
anime productions you choose to accept
what
led you to choose this particular anime
production
music
now we're going to the actual hand-drawn
parts
that was the digital department so now
we're going to see anime was drawn by a
good old pen and paper
digitally
foreign
were there any challenges in adapting a
light novel as opposed to an
um a manga or any other kind of source
material
industry
how does each animator choose which cuts
that they get
today
what factors goes into choosing the
exact titles that will get animated here
at jc stuff
foreign
foreign
so does that mean if it's a line of
adaptation you're given more freedom
to put your own vision into it because
with the manga it's
obviously drawn and it's almost like a
storyboard already
foreign
foreign
so we're heading into the background
department now we've just gone from
we've gone to a completely different
floor
so let's see what they're up to here
foreign
so per episode you can get between 300
to 400 backgrounds per episode how long
does it usually take to do one single
background
an hour or two to an entire day per
background
and they only appear on screen for a few
seconds as well so uh
that's a really short time for the
amount of effort you're putting in per
background can i
ask which one was the most difficult
background to draw for the episode that
he's
worked on
foreign what reference material do you
use to make the backgrounds
i didn't realize how much work went
through the backgrounds of the shows
not many people talk about background
artists as opposed to actual animators
so this is actually really interesting
to me how many background artists do you
have working on a one episode normally
five people just five in jc staff they
have five people working on backgrounds
which
it's not a lot for the amount of
backgrounds they need to draw per
episode
my god before adapting uh an anime how
much research do you as a director have
to put into the source material
i'm curious because obviously you know
most people in anime industry are like a
fan
of anime and manga um is reading a light
novel for
preparation for work different to you
than just reading just to enjoy
i know
foreign
one thing that i've always wondered is
it
for me as an oversea fan the japanese
companies made
anime for japanese people and that was
sold overseas but it feels like
recently the overseas fan has a bigger
voice here in japan
for yourself do you take overseas fans
into a counter tour whenever making a
product
or is that something you don't consider
at all
so there's every other colorist have to
follow her reference sheets
foreign there any new specific
challenges you found doing combatants
will be dispatched
to
[Music]
what's this stage of the process called
digital
well is this this part of the process
where you sync it to the voice as well
on the voice acting and the sound
effects
since the sound effects voice is on such
early stage
is it sometimes hard to sync it up or is
there any any problems when it comes to
this stage
the comedy timing the kami style was
obviously very similar to
konosuba because it's the same author so
i was curious
how much if you took any inspiration
from konosuba's adaptation when doing
this as well
i'm curious because it is a comedy show
because
you have to see a scene a lot of times
like
during production is there a time where
you have a joke but because you've seen
it so many times you
are worried that you don't find it funny
anymore but people around you will still
find it funny
so when you're adapting a piece of work
how much
contact do you have with the original
author or how much say did they have to
influence the final anime
do you have any message you have to any
fans who are watching combatants will be
dispatched right now
you need
and that was my day there huge thank you
to the people at jc staff for letting me
go there and show me around
and of course thank you to katakawa for
giving me the opportunity to go to an
anime studio
like what initially i did want this to
be a much bigger project going through
the entire life cycle and showing you
guys how a title like this gets picked
up from being a web novel
to a light novel to a manga and
eventually an anime adaptation
but unfortunately due to us being in
lockdown right now none of the staff
members or authors or editors
could be scheduled for an interview
understandably so but maybe in the
future i'll get another opportunity to
be able to show you guys the entire life
cycle behind your favorite anime being
made
combatants will be dispatched is airing
right now and you can watch it on
funimation work anime and anime lab
depending on where in the world you're
situated in and of course you can even
pick up
the light novel and also the manga yes
these are available physically
but you can also read them digitally
right now on
daddy bookwalker this video was
technically sponsored by bookwalker so
you can read it on that platform but
there are a lot of companies involved so
thank you to everyone who helped
coordinate this and make this video
possible and hopefully future videos
like this
hopefully i'll have more cool things
like this to show you in the future
in the meantime though thank you for
sticking around i've been gig up and
i'll see you all
next time